[Music]
maybe if you've fallen for this viral
internet prank or you know someone who
has you click on a link thinking it's
one thing and then boom
but there is rick astley dancing to
never gonna give you up that means you
have been rick ross the 80s pop
sensation is having a remarkable career
resurgence anthony mason traveled to
london to chat with the 56 year old
singer at mckellar brew pub which ashley
co-owns anthony good morning good
morning in a way i was rick rolled way
back in 1987
when i was assigned to the cbs london
bureau and just as i got there a
babyface singer with a rich baritone was
bursting onto the british music scene
three and a half decades later i finally
got to meet rick astley
[Music]
for 35 years it's been rick astley's
calling card
[Music]
that record just won't
die
have there been times he wanted it no no
no no i'm kind of joking in that way but
i can imagine some people want it to die
the video of his 1987 smash has been
viewed more than 1.2 billion times i've
got a very special relationship with
that song it's been unbelievably good to
me and keeps being good to me aslee is
singing it again this summer on the
mixtape tour crossing the country with
new kids on the block salt and peppa and
envo and then we've made this crazy
video it's a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun doing it
[Music]
bring back the time recreate scenes from
some of the 80s most iconic videos
you're parroting the david byrne video
right indeed yeah i hope he doesn't see
it that's all i could say everyone else
can watch it just not david where are we
going next
this is very nice come on
[Music]
this is ashley's home for the
three-month tour rick and his wife lena
who's also his manager won't always be
sleeping on the bus but you're kind of
living out of it we are living out of it
yeah you're okay being on a bus for
three months uh
yeah but we do punctuate it with very
nice hotels sometimes so that's
you know but it's a long road some 50
gigs this is the whole tour this is the
whole thing oh my gosh you really do all
go all the way around like we do so we
started here yeah we've been there we've
been there we're on our way to here
ashley was passing through nashville
when we caught up with him and looking
forward to a night off in dallas to see
a paul mccartney concert i'm not ashamed
to say i cried my eyes out at the end of
it as the fanboy later posted on
instagram i won't forget that night for
a very very long time
astley's career was launched in 1985
when a producer caught a gig near
manchester england how did he pitch you
at the time he had a jaguar and leather
pants you didn't need to say any more
than that
that was the pitch
he moved to london working in the studio
at first so i ended up making the tea
and the coffee and getting the
sandwiches you were bringing tea to
banana rama i was i was
[Music]
astley would bring his own wardrobe to
the video shoot for his first single i
turned up in a cab with a bag full of
clothes
double denim i'm like what are we doing
stand against that chain link fence and
dance
off you go son
[Music]
never gonna give you up went to number
one in 25 countries astley would have a
run of top 10 hits in the uk and the us
[Music]
but he began to sour on pop stardom
and in 1993 at age 27
he quit i don't want it to ever come
across as like i was making this sort of
you know statement throwing the scarf
behind and
off into the sunset you know of like i'm
done with this pop career it was just
like
i wasn't really enjoying it
um i think i'd had my moment you
basically didn't perform for what 15
years yeah
did a few weddings
friends weddings family weddings always
sang never going to give you up at
weddings yes
never got paid for it but weddings yeah
did you miss it at all
um
no i don't think it did if i'm honest
but two events would finally coax him
out of retirement a uk promoter
persuaded him to do a short tour
i think we've just been rick rolled at
the same time an internet phenomenon was
bringing back his biggest song
no
no
but his daughter emily a teenager at the
time had to explain rick rowling to her
death and she said you do realize it's
got nothing to do with you
i'm like
of course you're absolutely right it has
given the song a whole other life i am
grateful for it and
i've i've learned to roll with it i
haven't got any choice that's the other
thing i've got no way of stopping it
yeah i can't say to the internet by the
way i've had enough now and when the
song was featured in the apple tv plus
series ted lasso never gonna give you
never gonna let you
down
astley was surprised
and touched i was really really really
moved
with the church scene
[Music]
why were you so moved by it in the
church
she uses that
as a eulogy to a dead father that's like
i'm getting a bit like that now that's
pretty amazing
on the mixtape tour rick astley is
singing his hits again
but backstage he warms up to frank
sinatra so you do sinatra in your
dressing room before the show yeah yeah
yeah
i'd pay to see that show okay well i'll
i'll record it one evening i'll send you
a message
last night
[Music]
his wife lena caught him from behind the
dressing room door
[Music]
anyway i think i'm done for the day so
i'll see you later
bye ricky
[Music]
rick astley and his wife lena are two of
the loveliest people i have ever met
both of them on that bus that day were
fighting colds not fun when you're on
tour but they put up with us and let us
come along for the ride really lovely
folks
very excited to learn that in the video
he shows up in the 80s he gets the denim
on denim
go dance in front of the fence off you
go and who knew what was happening that
day you know what i didn't think about
until this piece the ted lasso thing
when they were singing that i thought
what a great moment i never thought i
wonder what rick astley feels yeah you
know and to think that i think that he
had i think he was probably afraid
people were making fun of him and his
daughter was saying no it's not yes
we're not making fun of it and he's back
to having fun back to having fun
certainly back to having fun that's
awesome anthony well done once again